aulas si saint méloir où j'ai 36 ans
j'habite au tampon donc je suis le seul
coutelier forgeron de l'île de la
réunion donc je fais ce métier-là depuis
maintenant trois ans officiellement ce
qu avant je le faisais pour ma passion
elle même c'est beaucoup de patience de
recherche et faut avoir cent soit il
faut vraiment aimer ce qu'on fait pour
moi je fais quasiment pas croquis pas de
dessin soit vraiment spécifiquement
quand on me le demande pour des clients
pour des les réalisations personnelles
spécifique pour les gens là je fais des
croquis des dessins spécifique sur
autocad ou autres et après que je
reproduis mais sinon je forge et je
laisse la simpar clé on va porter
l'acier à une certaine température en
fonction de justement des
caractéristiques de ces pastilles et là
en forge donc on va le forger à savoir
que plus on chauffe l'acier plus on va
le mettre longtemps dans la forge plus
vaste des carburants donc il faut
travailler vite pour donner rapidement
la forme au couteau pour justement que
l'acier garçons maximum de de qualité
moi j'utilise entre dix et quinze
dossiers différents pourquoi parce que
chaque acier a une caractéristique
spécifique une fois la lame forgée mise
en forme qu'on la laisse doucement dans
la cendre finançables dans la forge
elle-même pour baisser doucement en
température ensuite vient les tables de
la mise en forme du couteau les moutures
c'est à dire on fait le tranchant une
fois qu'on voit que la ci est bon être
trempé là on le trompe donc soit à l'eau
soit l'huile ou soit les deux ça dépend
là j'ai repris le couteau traditionnel
réunionnais
que tout le monde connaît pour un petit
couteau comme ça faut compter entre 5 et
8 heures pour pour le fabriquer
entièrement un bon coup de cuisine ou un
bon service à couteau on peut le
transmettre à son enfant il
retransmettra son petit enfant a plus
tard donc c'est des couteaux qui peuvent
passer 100 200 ans facilement si on et
d'entretien
je m'appelle marie dô au fleury je suis
décor actrice sur porcelaine j'ai débuté
en
1996 en autodidacte et en 1998 j'ai pu
acheter mon tout premier four 99 j'ai pu
participer à mon premier fait main avec
l'association arts et traditions
ça m'a servi en quelque sorte de
tremplin
j'ai pu présenter mes produits et voir
si ça plaisait ça m'a encouragé donc
aller de plus en plus loin il donc
j'achète de la vaisselle blanche en
porcelaine parfois dugré parfois de la
faïence et pour décorer donc ces pièces
en porcelaine on utilise des pigments
ils sont des oxydes de minéraux broyer
ses pigments ces poudres sont préparés
avec un médium qui est un mélange de thé
léventine fluide et de térébenthine
épaissi le décor est entièrement peints
à la main au pinceau parfois à l'épongé
on laisse sécher on pourra le passé donc
en cuisson et donc à 8 150 degrés
le brillant de la porcelaine est en
fusion les la peinture le décor qu'on a
peint dessus est également en fusion et
au refroidissement ça sera complètement
intégré l'un dans l'autre comme une
vitrification c'est inaltérable ça
craint le couteau bien sûr donc c'est à
manipuler quand même avec précaution
mais ça passe en lave vaisselle ça passe
au four pour un gratin pour chauffer une
assiette ça passe au four micro-ondes et
fours traditionnels et ce qui plaît une
année ne plaira pas forcément l'année
suivante il faut tout le temps se
renouveler tout le temps essayer de
trouver de nouvelles idées de manière à
ce que les gens aient l'impression de
nous re découvrir à chaque fois les gens
savent que lorsqu'on me commande quelque
chose je vais prendre le temps qu'il
faut mais ça sera soigné est le plus
parfait possible déjà rien que le fait
que la personne me disent que ça lui
plaît et que c'est beau c'est quelque
chose qui est déjà très important pour
moi
aulas